[Music]
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is written
and directed once again by James Gunn
who made the very fresh and very
exciting original film that said hey MCU
let's just have some fun let's take some
Walkmans and listen to music you know
and dance like Michael Jackson and this
time around our hero star-lord played by
Chris Pratt and the guardians of the
galaxy are now friends they go on little
missions together they do things they're
clearly like the ragtag team of really
cool people who do things and sometimes
they get paid you know I mean we've
never really seen that before and
anything that's never really been a
thing before he knocks it's all good all
jokes aside this movie is about
star-lord in his lineage who was his
father where did he come from is there
something special or different about him
or is he just another Han Solo type guy
who goes around the galaxy in fact this
film explores the origins and the
traumatic pasts of most of our hero
characters and some of our villain
characters too it's not just about
making a bigger better movie because as
we know that's pretty much what we
expect when we go to a sequel we want it
to be 2 times the action 2 times the
emotion 2 times the body counts 2 times
the explosion and if we're lucky maybe 5
times the explosions this some subverts
that notion and makes it less of a
bigger exciting action film and makes it
a lot bigger for the characters the
things that everyone goes through in
this movie makes them less of the fun
guys that are cool James Gunn clearly
isn't just content with keeping these
characters in that box
it makes the characters considerably
more fleshed out the things that
happened in this movie explore the
things that made them who they are we
learn more about each and every one of
them and so it gives the characters
considerably more weight it gives them
more reasons to show up in movies beyond
the fun guys who listen to old music and
make
folks and quips and the cute raccoon and
the cute little baby tree monster it's
not just those things this movie
of course exploits that heavily baby
Groot is an easy laugh and a genius move
on the part of James Gunn because you
instantly just look at him and you're
like yep you got me I'm there I love it
didn't take much you got me and he could
have just retread similar ground and had
a lot of really exciting action
sequences and had everybody tell jokes
and not really give an attempt or a
reason to make these characters feel
like they have a place in this universe
beyond the fun cool guys but he didn't
he took each and every one of them in
particular star-lord in this movie and
gave us a lot more reasons to care let's
talk about Kurt Russell if you already
have an affinity for Kurt Russell going
into this movie you will probably enjoy
his rugged charms but his character
could have been written better he is
often reduced to long expository
sequences where he explains everything
about him in his past and it's meant to
impress but it just kind of comes off
bland but the real strength of this
movie isn't necessarily that it has
really exciting action sequences which
it does it's the fact that James Gunn
has taken pretty much every character
safer I would say Drax and pinpointed
the traumatic details of their past that
has made them into who they are today
and opened the door to flesh out the
characters so much more emotionally like
yondu in particular Michael Rooker is so
good here a lot better than he was in
the first one and a lot of it has to do
with his characters writing we learned
so much more about him here and it
really makes me care a lot more about
that character Rocket also has to face
why he does things why does he steal
random things when he doesn't
necessarily have to what is he trying to
prove what's he looking for in life he
doesn't have that connection that he had
with Groot in the first one anymore
because baby Groot also has the mind of
a baby so he's kind of dumb and you have
to explain everything to him so he
doesn't necessarily have that same
friendship that he had with Groot and so
this film doesn't rely on that for
rocket it gives us a lot of other
reasons to feel for him in this movie
and to make him more of a
flesh-and-blood character and not just
the cute raccoon who's really badass if
you've seen the first guardians you know
that nebula
and Gomorrha our sisters raised by
Thanos being raised by Thanos I imagine
is a terrible thing but we haven't
really learned why what exactly made
nebula so evil and why is Gamora a
little bit more level-headed well in
this film we find out and I won't get
into it of course but the reasons are
kind of heartbreaking and extremely
tragic for nebula in particular and when
you think about that past it definitely
gives you something to attach to this
character she is still kind of overdoing
the performance a little bit but nebula
is considerably more of a human being
now even though a lot of these
characters aren't human beings this
movie explores their imperfections
extremely well and so in that way this
film isn't bigger in an action
standpoint in a world building
standpoint it's bigger for each of these
characters because the majority of them
discover or learn something extremely
important about themselves and it just
makes them more like people and less
like the quick machine characters that I
loved from the first one but now I do
feel like they have more of a solid
ground to stand on for future
installments now I said Drax got the
least amount of characterization in this
movie and that's true he's kind of a set
in stone character when you meet him in
the first film he is what he is
it's his attachment that he grows to
develop with the other guardians of the
galaxy that make him so likable and of
course his very twisted way of looking
at things so yes he gets the least
amount of characterization but I think
James Gunn could kind of tell as he
wrote the script because Drax has all
the best lines he is easily the funniest
part of this movie and Batista owned the
comedy which is something that James
Gunn brings here extremely well a great
sense of humor once again this is a
really funny movie historically Marvel
has a hard time with great villains DC
is very good with villains they tend to
have considerably better villainous
characters and in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 these gold people that are
stolen from in the very beginning of the
film follow them throughout the majority
of the movie they pop up at various
parts of the galaxy following the
Guardians and you're like can this scene
just end because these characters are
useless and completely disposable I
found myself mentally willing the scenes
that included them
to just end because I was pretty sure
that whatever came directly after that
was going to be a lot more fun I would
say like the first hour of volume 2 felt
a bit choppy there are times where the
emotion is riding high you're feeling
very much so for the characters as they
discover things about their past and
then there are times where it goes back
to these people decked out in gold and
they're chasing them because of some
stolen property and then there'll be a
comedic prison break sequence and it
just doesn't flow quite as well as the
first one did and some of that
choppiness is due to those decked out in
gold villains I just really don't need
them in this film at all the after
credit scene kind of gives them a
purpose but that's the after credit
scene like their place in this movie
it's just unwarranted I really did not
need them to be in this movie but I
understand the film has to have some
kind of an antagonist and it's just kind
of like play but towards the end I was
surprised to feel a lot of the emotional
beats were really well earned I found
myself getting emotionally wrapped up in
the ending I will say this though
sometimes not saying something is more
powerful than just saying it in the last
few minutes of the movie I found myself
getting really into the moment and I was
feeling exactly what Gunn wanted me to
feel but then someone told me what I
should feel and I was like I was already
I was already on your wavelength buddy
not necessary so sometimes the dialogue
overstates itself it doesn't necessarily
have to say certain things that it says
but because those characters were so
well set up in the first and second act
certain things that happen towards the
last few minutes it got me I was wrapped
up in it and that's because as I said
this film isn't necessarily bigger and
better than the first but it's bigger in
the sense of the implications of its
main characters of the heroes and some
of the villains I'm gonna give guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 a B+ not quite as
good as the first one not quite as fresh
not necessarily as exciting but it does
more for the characters this time around
to strengthen their bond and give us
more reasons to be excited about seeing
them come back guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]